-Welcome. Welcome back.
So happy to see you in person.
-I'm so happy to see -- You know
what I found out back there?
It's my sixth time here.
-Yeah.
-Isn't that amazing?
-Does it feel like six times?
-I don't know. I just --
-We have fun every time.
-Every time. Thank you.
I love being here.
I love watching it.
And I got a lot of love
for all of you here.
-Oh, we love having you here.
-Lot of love.
-I didn't get a chance to tell
you happy birthday.
Happy 27th birthday, right?
Yeah, this is a big deal.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But here is what
I think is very funny.
You celebrated your
21st birthday.
-I did.
-Now, why did it take you
so long to celebrate your 21st?
-I turned 21 when I was
shooting in Vancouver,
and the legal drinking age
there is 18.
So when I went around being
like, "It's my 21st!",
people were like, "Okay."
And then, the next year --
-It's like, "Yeah, that's fine."
-You know, I thought
maybe I'd celebrate it
the next year and the next year,
and it never happened.
And, finally, this year,
post-booster, of course,
I celebrated my 21st birthday
six years later.
-That's right.
Why not?
-I know. And I did it up.
I went to Vegas,
and it was, like,
the most Vegas-y birthday ever.
Me and my friends --
we flew in this cool airplane.
We took a party bus to
the Vegas sign.
Tiesto sang me "Happy Birthday."
I gambled.
-Look at you and Tiesto.
I mean, I love Tiesto.
-He's my best friend now.
-We saw Tiesto when we
first started "Late Night"
and we took all the writers.
We went to a trip to
Atlantic City and saw Tiesto.
And it was amazing.
And then I think his booth
turned into a robot and
had lasers and started
coming into the audience.
People were freaking out.
-No.
-Yeah.
-Are you sure
that really happened or...
-No. We were just doing --
Yeah, no, sure.
-I don't know if we're allowed
to talk about that here.
-You did do a lot of gambling.
-Yeah.
-And, so, I wanted to show this.
Not to show off or anything,
but this is your
cash-out ticket in Las Vegas.
Not too shabby.
Look at this right here.
24 cents.
Wow!
-Yeah.
-What were you playing
and what were you losing?
-Slots.
And I was losing it all, baby.
-Yeah, just have fun. Why not?
I love this.
You even had birthday hats
made that says
"Zoey's 27th/21st birthday."
Yeah, I love those hats.
-You're only 21 twice, so...
-You could do it every year.
Come on.
-Yeah, come on.
-You know every time
you come on, we play games.
We've done bits together.
-I love bits.
-Yes. You always do --
-I live for bits.
-Yes. That's why we love having
you on the show.
But you brought
me a game this time.
-I brought you a bit.
-Which no one
ever brings me a game.
-I know.
-This is exciting.
-I thought it wasn't fair.
So, I grew up -- My father
and my grandmother always used
a lot of Yiddish words
and phrases.
It was a part of
the family lexicon.
And I feel like you probably
know some Yiddish words.
And you guys probably know some
Yiddish words, like "oy vey."
Do you know "oy vey?"
-Of course, yeah.
-Do you know "klutz?"
-Yes.
-Spiel.
-Yeah.
-Okay, great.
So you know a little bit.
-This is good.
-Right? We're starting off well.
I picked some little bit more
advanced Yiddish words.
I'm going to say the word,
give you two definitions,
and you're going to guess
which one it is.
-Alright. I'm very competitive.
I love this.
-The first one is mishpucha.
-Oh, I know this.
-"A," an unforeseen mishap,
or, "B," family?
-Mishpucha.
-And what are the two --
One is an unforeseen thing,
and one is family.
I think it's family.
"You're my mishpucha."
[ Ding ]
-That's correct!
-Really?!
-Yeah!
-See? I know more Yiddish.
I felt like it was "family."
-Yeah, the whole mishpucha.
Let's bring the
whole mishpucha to Vegas.
-I love Yiddish. Alright, good.
-The second one -- You're gonna
be fluent in no time, guys.
-I know.
Look at what we're learning.
-Two -- shayna punim.
"A," a dish containing potatoes,
or "B," a pretty face?
-Punim is "face," I want to say.
-You are crushing this.
[ Ding ]
-This is unbelievable?
And I did not...
What was it? Shayna punim?
-Shayna punim.
Like, "Oh, what a shayna punim."
-"Oh, shayna punim"?
-Yeah. Right.
-Wow.
You are real good.
-This is awesome.
I did not plan this out.
This is exciting for me.
I love this. Alright.
-The last one.
All three of these words
mean the same thing.
Schmegege.
-I love schmegege.
-I know, schmegege.
-Just saying it.
-Everyone just say it with me.
-Schmegege.
-Schmegege!
-Alright, aren't you having fun?
Schmegege?
-It's actually great. Schmegege.
-It's schmegege.
Schmegege, schmendrick,
and schmo.
-Schmendrick.
-Yeah, schmendrick.
"A," these are all words for
a silly or stupid person,
or, "B," these are all
affectionate terms for a baby.
-It's got to be
the first one, right?
-Oh, my God.
-Look at me! Oh, my God!
Am I...
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Really? Respect?
Respect, right?
-Yeah, you earned it.
-Respect right there? Come on.
Dude, that's -- Right?
Not bad?
I did not --
Dude, we did not plan it.
I love it.
-I have no words.
-Schmegege.
That's the best word
I've ever heard.
-I love schmegege.
-Schmegege?
I mean, that's --
You guys are going to be using
that every day now.
-Now, yeah, we're
always going to say schmegege
when we come out.
I want to talk about your movie.
That's why you're here.
This is, like -- "The Outfit."
-Yeah.
-By the way, every time you come
on, you have different movies,
and you have great accents
in the movie.
And this is another one that you
can add to your repertoire.
What -- Is this,
like, a Chicago?
-Yeah, it's, like,
a 1950s Chicago accent.
And I was so -- I really
wanted this movie.
It was such a cool script.
And Mark Rylance, who's one of
the greatest actors
of all time -- I was really
nervous to work with him.
And it was shooting in London.
I knew I had to
prepare properly,
so I went to go see a dialect
coach, get the accent great.
I came to the first day
of rehearsal, and everybody --
Excluding Mark,
who's playing an Englishman,
everybody had
this distinct Chicago accent.
I had a
completely different accent.
I showed up with, like, a really
bizarre Mid-Atlantic accent.
I started talking
like this, darling.
Like, the entire movie,
I'm just talking like this,
and Mark Rylance
is looking at me like,
"What is this American doing?"
-What is going...
But it's just, "Darling --"
-"Darling, darling.
It's so great to
see you, darling."
Like, it just -- It looked like
I was a really bad imitation
of an old movie.
And that was mortifying,
but, eventually,
I got it.
I went to the director,
I was like, "Don't say anything.
I got it.
Tomorrow, it'll be Chicago,
and the Mid-Atlantic
will be in the trash."
It was -- Yeah.
-But what different accents
can you do right now?
Can we just rattle some off?
-Oh, rattle some.
-Give me --
-Well, I feel like,
honestly, like,
the first one that comes to mind
is the accent I did
in "Zombieland," because, like,
it's, like,
inspired by the Valley and
I'm literally from the Valley.
-Wow. That's perfect.
-And, like...
You know,
you're so good at accents,
and Minnesotan is so much fun.
Minnesotan -- don't cha know? --
is such a fun accent to do.
-Oh, Minnesota, yeah.
-Yeah?
-Yeah. Love Minnesota.
-Oh, yeah.
-Oh, yeah. Of course.
I'm gonna just keep
copying you now.
-Oh, you are?
-Yeah, why not?
-Well...
-...now...
-...I'm gonna do a...
-...Southern person.
-That's exactly right.
-And welcome to the show,
and you're just --
-Welcome to the show, now.
I love Southern,
but you know what I have to say?
I think my favorite accent
of all is an accent
that comes from a town
not so far from here, Jimmy.
-Where is that, now?
-Long Island.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You love the Long Island?
-Yeah, my grandmother,
the one who taught us all that
Yiddish earlier
that you were so good at --
she is from Long Island.
-Oh, my God.
-She's from Long Island.
She talks like this.
It's amazing.
And if she were here,
she would tell you
you got a shayna punim.
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, I love you and I love her.
That's the next movie.
You've got to do that.
-Who is going to hire me
to do that accent?
-Oh, you have to do --
-I sound like
I smoke a pack a day,
but I've never had
a cigarette in my life.
-But that's perfect.
You're going to
rock that, trust me.
You're going to take that
and rock that in a movie.
Can we tell everyone what
"The Outfit" is about?
-Yes. "The Outfit"
is about an expert tailor
who has to outwit a bunch
of very dangerous gangsters
in order to survive a night.
The movie takes place
in one night
on one set with six actors.
It's really cool.
It feels like a play.
And you are constantly trying to
tell who is telling the truth.
-Yeah. And it's you,
Mark Rylance. Come on.
I want to see this.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Zoey Deutch in
"The Outfit."
Take a look.
-I do not need you
telling me who to date.
-I didn't mean it like that.
-You meant it like,
"I saw you smiling
at Richie Boyle" earlier,
and now I'm petrified that
you're running with
a bad batch."
-Those men may be customers,
but they are not gentlemen.
-Could have fooled me in those
nice clothes you make for them.
-If we only allowed angels
to be customers,
then we'd have
no customers at all.
-Do we let all of our customers
keep locked boxes in back?
-It was you who was
smiling at him.
-I've spent my entire life
around animals
like Richie Boyle.
You want to get them
to back off,
you look them dead in the eyes
and you pretend
you're one of them.
-You don't need me
worrying after you.
-That's right.
-Oh! Zoey Deutch, everybody!
"The Outfit"
is in theaters March 18th.